[موسيقى]
لقد قمنا برفع الاحتياطيات لكم جميعًا
كل الأرباح
لعبت مفرزة من المدينة الإقليمية
[موسيقى]
هنا أقول أن هناك عمليات في
في الوقت الحالي ، يعمل الأطباء على إيجاد طرق للتهديد
المجموع
ها هم أبطال يعملون من أجل لا شيء
يصرف
[موسيقى]
ربما حتى لا يدخل الدخان
أغلقنا غرفة العمليات
كانت الأبواب مغلقة
الرطب فقط لم يكن تحت الباب
مزروعة
وحافظنا على الجو
مستقرة نسبيًا وبدون
دخان
[موسيقى]
لم يكن لدى الرجل مكان يذهب إليه
حفظ فعل كل شيء على أعلى مستوى مثل
يقول جراحة الشريان التاجي
مصطنعة الالتفافية الضيقة
الدورة الدموية كاملة وبدون
يجب أن تستمر الميزات لمواصلة كل شيء
لا تفعل أي قرار أي عملية
هل سينهيها
للأسف أو جزء من مرضاه
[موسيقى]